it's time for screen junkies movie
fights today's episode is brought to you
by shadow of the Tomb Raider available
September 14th pre-order now for two-day
early access
we're miles at hashtag owl nation movie
fights in full effect and this is a
momentous day the belt is on the line
let's not
jibber-jabber anymore let's meet the
competitors first off he is the reigning
movie fights champion he wanted during
our special women in film event this is
his first title defense please welcome
to the table our felted friend cucumber
everybody glad to be here happy - happy
to fight these fellas I'm looking
forward to it hell yeah everyone is
waiting for your first title defense
with bated breath cucumber go ahead and
a plug what we're at work we're gonna be
seen regularly perception studio which
is twitch.tv slash perception studio or
you can just follow me at cucumber lives
and I'll link you wherever you like
great great
all right well cucumber best of luck
today
this gentleman has stormed into movie
fights lately he's put up an impressive
record and just really shown himself as
a top contender he's one of the hosts of
the nerd goat podcast it's ed Grier hey
guys it's really great to be here house
yeah ed good to have you back what's
going on you unplug something or just
tell us how you prepared for this or
anything at all well you know if you put
a note card on your steering wheel it's
a pretty cool table so I did that on the
way here I got a little couple scribbles
down no III would not disrespect these
guys by not preparing right on uh this
is this is a great bouton let's get it
on yes also be careful of ed he sounds
like a danger on the road you know this
guy he's a legend when it comes to movie
related games and competitions he's held
all the belts the longest-reigning movie
fights champion in history Dan Morelle
dan what's up brother
I'm so excited I've been waiting for
this moment since the Spencer Gilbert
swooped in and stole that belt off of my
shoulder got a long road this will be my
first time fighting cucumber I look
forward to that and I
to fight and claw pass to get to this
seat to begin with so I know how hard
it's gonna be to fight that I can't wait
I wore my jaw shirt just for you
cucumber you seem very enamored with it
experience than you do so wow there's a
lot of bad blood at this table or
whatever flows through the felted
friends Oh Dan real quick before we move
on I wanted to get just your your quick
hot take so they pulled the most popular
category from the Oscars they didn't
think about that I say that they needed
to do that because other than the naming
it the most popular Oscar they had no
idea what it was for months it's right
something like that so yeah good good
call yeah let's beta tester workshop it
a little bit really workshop that thing
that wasn't even beta tested it's like
they came up with that idea five minutes
before the press conference so totally
good call Academy and I have my personal
opinion is unless they really retool it
I hope it goes away forever
right on Dan thank you now deciding the
match will be myself and we have the Dan
cam except instead of the Dan today
we've got a lawn on the fact checking
hoot-hoot what up lawn on Harris it's a
lawn dad cam yes just for audience in
case you did get the message don't know
take and drive it's almost as bad as
texting and driving it super arrested
that's yeah that's really against the
law yeah for sure for sure thank you for
that public service announcement that's
what I'm here for it yes so during the
three regular rounds lawn and I will be
weighing in with our pension our our
opinions and
sure why not and then the voice of the
people the conduit of the Internet's
decisions Daniele Radford on an angel
among us Danielle sent from heaven above
to be a conduit of the people oh hello I
was actually looking at things and
forgot that I would be on camera soon hi
so the way that this works is that yes I
am you I am your voice we will be having
a poll on YouTube there are very fun
polls that you can do on our hashtag
movie fights live but the only poll that
counts for this is the YouTube poll we
will be checking in with those every
round however the only time that matters
is in the event of a tie then that poll
actually becomes a tied vote if you're
not sure how to vote click down in the
description we've got all the
instructions there you can check inside
the chat people will be copy pasting
stuff to let you know how that works
and then in the speed round no more
polls cuz I have to vote for myself and
my own opinions which so looks mean
whatever as long as you make a decision
on who I know why you don't you always
have like good takes but you always hate
breaking people's hearts I don't like it
yeah hearts are gonna get broken today
because it's a fight it's a movie fight
and again how it works we have three
regular round questions and then we go
to the speed round so we'll get me down
three-zip going in to the speed round
when our two players go in but the
player is down can come all the way back
so yeah are you all ready man good
alright jte will drop the package
[Music]
time
Thank You Thor alright question number
one again the belt is on the line there
it is what is the best live-action movie
that everyone of all ages can enjoy
equally okay the best live-action movie
equally player number one cucumber we
start with you alright gotta go with
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles it's a gift
that just keeps on giving when you're a
kid you love it for the radical Turtles
the martial arts the pizza terrifying
shredder nearly everything is quotable
delightful you got four distinct turtles
with kick-ass weapons attitude crack and
wise when you're a teen you'll have it
for the craftsmanship you know all those
wonderful suits and then you enjoy the
sets and all of that as well and then
you know April O'Neil Casey Jones starts
to make sense that that wonderful
relationships that builds and then as an
adult you get to laugh at some of the
unfinished qualities in the movie like
the hanging matte paintings and the
phases beyond the teeth of the giant
turtle faces it's just nothing but joy
from beginning to end and pork rinds
pork rinds alright I guess we'll
elaborate more on the pork rinds shortly
thank you cucumber Edie my choice was
the Princess Bride and it's one of these
movies that keeps being bandied about as
like the perfect movie as a movie that
you can watch with all ages and I really
started examining it can be watched by
all ages it has story elements that can
engage adults most of the time people
talk about you know things that could be
watching of all ages they're mostly
talking about kids movies with a couple
of minutes for adults
this whole thing is adults seeing kids
movies through a kid's eyes through the
narrative device of the storytelling so
it's a it's a grand fable and I think it
is for all ages and I shall I'll prove
that today thanks ed dan Moreau
I picked a film that I grew up calling
Star Wars so I'm just gonna call it Star
Wars it's an alibi a necessity of
franchise called Star Wars Episode four
a new home but let's just call it Star
Wars here on the show this is no pun
intended but it's one of the most
Universal films ever made and it's not
just because the care
a popular but the character got popular
after the show came out it became
popular for a reason and it's because
George Lucas smartly said fantasy sci-fi
all of these genre things are so hit or
miss a lot of new people just see ray
guns and they think that it's kid stuff
literally kid stuff you said I'm going
to take the monomyth I'm going to take
the basis of the DNA from which every
great story is ever told and inject it
with this genre filmmaking and what it
has become is a global icon it is a
movie that you people recognize all over
the planet generations have attached
themselves to it it's with 40 plus years
old at this point and still finding fans
still finding popularity and the reason
why it's so popular isn't because it's
about space or spaceships it's because
it is a universal story and George Lucas
was smart enough to tap into that that's
why it's connected so well and that's
why I think it can be enjoyed by anyone
of any age anywhere on the planet all
right three very different movies
gentlemen and felted friend fight it out
well III I'd like to I'd like to just
take on the elephant in the room besides
me and that is Just Dance Captain
America shield of using Star Wars at all
I just I rebuke that Satan I I really
think that that's underhanded as hell
because everybody knows how popular it
is and let me tell you why it's still
popular and why it's still engaging
imaginations a blow-by-blow it's because
it's a toy goldmine they're still making
these movies for toys and for licensing
and it isn't because of the enduring
power of the fable my movie has made
hundreds of millions of dollars in
streams and video since its since it got
dropped and and you know when it
originally got dropped in the 80s and
basically it mates it was made for
sixteen million dollars made thirty
million dollars not stating hundreds of
million dollars that's our growing
enduring fable and not because of toys
because of the damn story Star Wars sold
quite a few DVDs of videotapes and it's
a day and age I think it's been released
in theaters way way way more than The
Princess Bride and again the reason why
is because there's an audience for it
across all spectrums I want to talk like
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles real
quickly because that is that is a movie
of my youth and I mean in your argument
you said that like kids kids and
teenagers will like it fine and then
adults will laugh at it it's because
how bad it is joy its everyone of all
ages equally and as somebody with
grandparents in the early 90s I can tell
you that people above 50 do not buy into
teenage Ninja Turtles understand it it's
stupid it's dumb it is propagandist it
teaches you all about the faceless enemy
right this is some world war ii [ __ ]
here we're just bad guys we don't know
anything about you know their their
overarching plan you don't know what
they're trying to do you don't know
anything about the rebellion in Episode
four they don't tell you crap so it farm
boy goes oh I think I'm gonna join the
Empire five seconds later oh I think I'm
gonna join the rebellion and then he
goes on to be indoctrinated by a
religion he's never heard of to then go
on and kill hundreds of thousands of
people because he kills more than one
person he's don't usually goddamn hero
it doesn't make any sense we're not
attacking the first of the logic of Star
Wars and secondly would Star Wars start
explaining what the Empire was and who
the rebellion was it started getting to
how everything worked that's when it got
bogged down in details Star Wars is a
hero and a villain a good guy and a bad
guy it speaks the universal language not
only of cinema but of character and
that's why it can be enjoyed cuz when
Han Solo comes swooping in on the
Millennium Falcon the five-year-old kid
is gonna love it because he's driving a
cool spaceship the 60-year old man
that's watching it it's gonna say John
Wayne it sees John Wayne swooping in on
horseback in that moment it is
iconography and that's why it is so
translatable and so popular I agree with
cucumber that Luke's the Luke Skywalker
is the most endearing jihadist ever I
definitely I definitely I definitely
agree with that but the thing about
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and
respectfully cucumber I got to say the
90s nostalgia tried but I gotta say it's
it's any anachronism or any sort of any
problem with the time is absolved by the
fact that it's a timeless fable whereas
your movie is so distinctly 90s I mean
this guy it's got moonlighting
it's got references to the show
moonlighting
and frankly has a fat person I hate that
the first time they beat up the Foot
Clan they get like one medium pizza I
think I remember also one last thing on
the team in Ninja Turtles one of your
opening points that I have to take issue
with is that you said that the turtles
have distinct personalities
I don't even know if Donatello really
does machines and the damn thing you
don't mean I think it's just Raphael and
a trenchcoat and that's the character
development I think they decided there's
a turtle and three other dudes that are
his brothers that's kind of what the
movie represents to me and that to me is
indistinct character development I want
to talk about Princess Bride nobody's
really talked about this you kind of
boiled down my counter-argument to which
you said The Princess Bride is adults
seeing kids fables through adult eyes
I think if again if you're talking to
it's not about if the movies good it's
not about the philosophy of the movie
we're just talking about a great movie
for anyone of any age to watch I think
that the Princess Bride is actually way
more enjoyable if you're an adult than
with when if you're a kid I remember
when I saw Princess Bride when I was you
know five six seven years old I kind of
checked out of it I was kind of bored by
it because so much of it is wordplay and
verbal and you know two turning turns on
phrase and Wallace Shawn making
references and stuff that I sort of
checked out plus the movie itself again
I've always thought is way more clever
in the first 45 minutes than it is in
the last 45 minutes
okay this bride is way more accessible
to adults and a little inaccessible to
kids okay if I may rebut though I've
tried to watch Star Wars the 1976 Marvel
or whatever with a seven-year-old today
and that kid boy you talked about check
out this kids a library because nothing
happens for 40 minutes then an innocent
person gets their hand chopped off
that's Star Wars in a nutshell nothing
happens the crawl happens we see a dark
dude indicate walk down a hallway
huge space battle for a seven-year-old
kid raised right now with today's
standards that is not a huge space
battle that's a lite-brite drop down the
stairs I'm sorry possible to meet
standards of what they are entertained
by but it's called 40 years and the fact
that they're not enamored with the toys
will sit and watch Mandy Patinkin talk
to Wallace Shawn on a boat for 10
minutes and not at some point it'd be
just like what's going on here I don't
understand what any of this man then
he'll watch a dude have a ninja fight
two seconds later that takes like 10
minutes and fights the princess that's a
beautiful thing about Princess Bride
is Wesley it you know what what what
Princess Bride boils down to it's a
fable with Batman in it he went off on a
long quest he learned a bunch of arcane
skills he came back with that to save
his true love rather than his city
that's the only difference between the
Dread Pirate Roberts in this movie and
Batman and I really think that that's
that's an action archetype that lat
that's even better than your farmboy
or a bunch of turtles from the 90s that
kids can't really do not to mention kids
get creeped out by Peter Fox I I love
Columbo so I'm not gonna just well the
kids always have one more question yeah
Leslie in Batman there's no Wesley it's
like the most boring version of Batman
in the world is very soft-spoken this is
about all ages and and it's been proven
this is a proven thing with Star Wars is
it it's the reason that it has endured
for so long is that it's not aiming for
kids like Ninja Turtles is it's not
aiming to look at a fairy tale like
Princess Bride is Princess Bride is a
riff on the fairy tale genre Star Wars
is a very straightforward story of good
and evil good guys and bad guys and if
you're older and you're a big sci-fi
nerds and it's got all the space stuff
in it if you're younger and you
really or literally at this point just
registering he's bad and he's good you
have people that you can automatically
route for people that you can
automatically sympathise with theirs
they use the dynamics of the hero's
journey and Dan go ahead and roll this
into your final shots the fact that
Lucas smartly said it's not just about
the accoutrement it's not just about the
things in the movie you have to tell a
great story
he gets crib he gets hit a lot for
cribbing from Joseph Campbell but
there's a reason that he did that it's
because he knew that the the structure
and the archetypes in that movie are
enduring enduring parts of a well-told
story stories that connect two
generations stories that from mythology
onto now I think that movies are in a
lot of ways modern mythology and I think
that what he did with Star Wars was find
a way to tell a great John retail but
construct characters and construct
dynamics between them so that if you are
five years old in that theater you know
what's going on you understand and you
connect to it but if you're 70 years old
you still find that hero to attach to
it's not exclusive it's not a bunch of
turtles dancing around and fighting
around what you're gonna buy into and
you're not and it's not kind of a hip
twist on the fairy tale genre which
again if you're into that and you want
to see that that that's fine it's very
inclusive
it's very accepting and it's very very
simple but also complex story that
people can connect to across every
spectrum and I think that's why it's the
movie that that it is and that's
connected to so many people and has been
really so many times thank you Dan back
around a cucumber cucumber give us your
final thoughts on TMNT well I still
stand by the fact that you can connect
all the turtles they're wonderful people
and yes maybe they didn't show off all
the tech for Donnie or Leo or whatever's
in there but here's the thing the great
thing about the turtles is that they
teach you humility it's all about doing
the right thing especially when no one
can see you right and that that's
something that that that they push
really hard but they just bury it you
know in the cheese jokes and and
splinter saying weird stuff and then
let's talk about the rescue right the
rescuing their mentor it's very engaging
they have an awesome cool smoke talk
with them it's a good time it's a good
time for everybody and then pork rinds
you guys
alright chicharones edy well the thing
that I think is neglected about Princess
Bride is we're talking about a movie of
all ages and it's literally the literary
the the framing device of the movie is a
grandpa with his grandson it's the
definition of an all-ages story that was
the question and that is the question I
am answering what is a movie that you
can pop in for all ages whether they've
seen a bunch of toys and cartoons for 40
years have been indoctrinated into this
into this weird space jihadist thing
that Star Wars is or or whether they've
been indoctrinated by a bunch of toys on
the 15 reboots of this movie no
independent of any sort of marketing any
independent of any sort of influence for
culturally or otherwise there's this
movie that exists and is discovered over
an over generation after generation by
children and parents that they can
actually put it and watch and enjoy for
two hours and that movie is the Princess
Bride and influenced by nothing else
other than a story told from a
grandparent to a grandson a real
all-ages story that continues to be
discovered over and over again that is
the Princess Bride and that answers this
question all right and that is our round
one Wow well fought everybody lon
hit us with some facts to two facts one
we got correct in the round Princess
Bride not a huge hit when it was first
released it earned about as much as
Ernest saves Christmas in theaters
around 30 million domestically my second
choice for this it's a movie that won
the Internet the internet really is
behind a lot of the continued fan -
behind Princess Bride I do have one fact
- correct there are no ninja fights and
Princess Bride
versus a Spanish swordsman note no
ninjas gotcha
okay so Q come we're gonna talk about
your answer first that means didn't win
this yeah I mean you it was an
interesting choice but I mean right in
your opening argument when you said
teens will love the craftsmanship of the
sets or something like that I'm like
okay teen cucumber did what when you
were just a little I think it's I think
it's a fun movie to watch it's a great
piece of nostalgia as Edie said it's got
a moonlighting reference in it but yeah
it didn't take it from me ed and Dan you
guys were just like trading blows I mean
just even I was listening it came down
and like listening to your final
arguments and like Dan had a line like
it's a genre film and anyone from like 5
to 70 and then Edie hit the grandfather
and the grandson is there's so much um I
think the thing that just edged by a
hair and when you said I think you were
goat you I think you put a little too
much cachet into the whole mythos of
Star Wars and all the toys and
everything and that catching everyone
and it's like I mean Dan kept like
what's he gonna do yeah it's a poison it
is a giant toy commercial it tells a lot
of toys I think we leaned into that a
little too hard and out that didn't help
your argument so but Dan's stuck to his
argument and Lucas's story tropes and
everything and just recognizing that the
good and evil and knowing what you're
seeing up there so by the slimmest of
margins I gotta go Dan long
yeah I'm gonna disagree with you a
little bit I do agree as much as I
celebrate the turtles I love the turtles
I agree this one came down to ad versus
Dan for me it was very it was very close
but I just say I really liked Ed's
argument that kids today because Star
Wars is so much about the spectacle so
much about the action they yeah that
maybe isn't gonna hold
as well for kids today as the comedy and
the characters and the things that
people sort of love about Princess Bride
so very close I think you can make a
very good case for either of these
movies but in the end I give the slight
edge to edge all right wow that's just
how close it was and Daniel Radford is
going to come in and tell us what's up
right now all right let me refresh so
everything is fresh and new hand with
54% we've got Star Wars a new hope
37% The Princess Bride 7% teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles some other ones some kind
of ones that we saw that came up in the
chat other suggestions et Wizard of Oz
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory but
overwhelming amounts of people on both
Twitter and in the chat said Back to the
Future oh that's a great answer true
true that get your damn hands off her
scene might be a little intense at this
all right so Dan Morelle taken the point
question number two okay Jennifer Garner
in peppermint it opens this weekend in
theaters what movie character would you
most like to avenge your death
okay who do you want to just get revenge
for you and question number two we'll
start with player number two ed Greer
well my choice may seem like a populist
choice for right now but I have thought
about this and I have read the comics
for years and the person I would most
want to revenge my death or avenge my
death is Thanos I think the mad Titan if
he cared about my life enough to be sad
that I was dead nothing could stop him
from killing literally nothing and we
can get into the myriad ways how nothing
could stop him from from you know
avenging me we could talk about that a
little later but you gotta just look at
that guy look at that guy that guy that
that guy cares about me and wants to
kill you that's all I gotta say about
that
she's got there all right the map Titan
Thanos
Dan when I saw this question I thought
about it for awhile I jake'd a few names
around and then it came to me like a
lightning bolt and I realized this is
the only answer to this question that I
could possibly fight okay and that is
John wick who else would you want
avenging anything but John wick
baba-yaga himself he I want to entrust
someone to to carry on my legacy I want
him to avenge my death so hard that no
one even looks at a member of my family
and anyone I ever met anybody ever said
hello to on the street avenging is about
leaving a mark beyond the grave and no
one does that better than John wick
because he's not gonna just avenge my
death he's going to cut a path of
destruction across everyone who caused
it everyone had a hand of it it was a
did he did he open the door for the guy
who caused it I want that guy in charge
of carrying on my name and my legacy
who's in actually avenge and revenge me
and that's John wick all right John wick
cucumber I gotta go with Darth Vader
that fellas entire story is just dipped
in revenge he's the chosen one he's
powerful in the force he killed those
and all those adjacent to those who
killed his mother he's a spirit of
violence and vengeance he's a force
wielding throat choking lightsaber swing
and murderous juggernaut interrogator
war tactician and ruthless foe he can
stop projectile weapons with his palm
and he can force throw just about
anything no one else stands a chance
against this guy he'll hack through one
excited I remember that scene okay
here's my thing about Darth Vader he is
certainly a badass but he could be
manipulated very very easily I want to
entrust this mission with someone who I
know is going to carry it out and if you
just look at his history of just like
I'm a Jedi I'm sworn to protect the
galaxy and then he like talks to a dude
in an opera and he's like I'm killing
all the children I'm killing all of them
right now and then he's a bad guy for 30
years and then his son shows up and he's
like I don't know I think you're a good
guy
Darth Vader is like you're right I'm a
good guy and now I'm killing them for
somebody that I'm actually gonna stick
to his gun as was proven in the previous
round the Skywalker clan is easily
swayed you can you can talk them into
stuff that they'd be Mormons if they
lived in Utah so I don't know man
cucumber I think overall overall
cinematic Thanos thing because he's not
particularly vengeful you know he didn't
even want any
he killed the one thing you loved but he
didn't want to do it and everyone that
he did kill he did it for the betterment
of all life in the universe he was doing
all these things for the right reasons
he's just happened to be a monster but
he does not strike me as vengeful well
to that point that's what he does when
he's just being altruistic imagine what
he'd do if he was actually out for
revenge that would be my counterpoint
but Thanos his life's mission is to
achieve what he finally achieved an
infinity war I don't think you're gonna
find anyone who's ever more motivated to
do anything than what he did and in this
film that was like his life's goal and
even then just judging by his history in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe if I want
him to avenge my death here's what he's
gonna do he's gonna say he's gonna do it
he's gonna sit in a chair and think
about it for a while he's gonna send
someone else to do it they're gonna fail
then he's gonna say he's gonna do it
again then he's gonna send some more
people to do it for him and then they're
gonna fail and then he's gonna like
maybe do it but by the skin of his teeth
I don't want that I don't want a
wishy-washy Avenger I want someone who
is going to come at you just with all
just like bullets and teeth and nails
and blood and that is John wick if his
mission is to avenge me he is not he's
gonna do it yesterday and he's not gonna
stop until the mission is done it
doesn't matter if he has to go through
five guys or 50 guys he's gonna get it
done III definitely understand but 50
guys is nothing to fan o's or any of his
emissaries
about the practicality of a guy with so
much gun tinnitus that he continuously
gets hit by cars wouldn't even register
bro that's what I'm saying I'm just
looking at this retractor all the car
yeah I just think overall it really
comes down to Darth Vader and and and
Thanos because look either one of them
would break John wick off a wrapper
unless John wick has to go through Darth
Vader fan hose in which case he will do
so easily and Thanos is not scared by
Western European fables he's shaking his
boots when the phone rings and there's
there's there's a crusty Johnny Utah
outside no I believe that Thanos look as
I stated earlier that was him being nice
for real this whole period isn't being
nice not want to do too much collateral
damage not one he went he money wanted
to let some the d'etat recon-car world
basically it wasn't a big deal but one
of this don't I mean only one of this
stuff I don't even think one of the
stalls was here yet one of the zones was
here at that time but the other one
wasn't so it wasn't a big deal to him
until now and now that it became a big
deal to him now that he came to do it
himself which I believe that's how he
would take my my you know revenge
he would avenge me because the whole
point of him prevent avenging one person
when he wants to kill half of life means
he cares about that person means he
would take that personally so no I don't
buy the argument that he would send
proxies to avenge me he already did it
he did it for the biggest achievement of
his life for years and years he just
sent other people to do his work for it
he's just all smiles and I was just
sitting on a mound somewhere smoking a
pipe or something got all this legs
cucumber
man that boot would kick through
somebody light saber force joking you
can kill you over a security cam like he
kills the women he kills the children
darth vader is unstoppable unless you
talk him out of what he's doing in which
case he's very stop okay yeah how many
people will actually listen to besides
those two but you know what what you
need and someone is going to avenge you
and I will make this my closing argument
how unless you wanna keep going what you
need and someone who is going to avenge
you you want someone with initiative and
the will to get it done and you want
somebody who's gonna stick to the
mission and stick to the principle
Santos is a very mighty mighty force but
he doesn't have the initiative to get it
done he stalls too much he appoints
other people to do it too much there's
too much margin for failure Darth Vader
doesn't have the principles he may
believe in something today but that
doesn't mean he's gonna believe in it
tomorrow he flip-flops all the time and
I don't want that in someone who's going
to avenge me I want somebody like John
wick who when he is motivated and when
he's been given a task to do when he
believes in it cuz if he's gonna avenge
my death and that means that this is
something that he believes in he's not
gonna stop until anything gets in his
way he's not gonna be intimidated by
numbers he's not gonna be intimidated by
difficulty by borders by boundaries he's
not going to stop until he is killed or
avenged the person responsible and what
more could you ask for to get that kind
of job done thanks Dan background a
cucumber what more could you ask for a
light show of blood I want that
lightsaber just cutting through people
like butter and I think yeah you know
what he kills people while he mows
things over he'll still get it done
before he makes up his mind he killing
him is so easy it's like breathing Darth
Vader would take care of it before I
even realized he did cuz he'd be through
like half of the building realizing oh
yeah probably that guy back there are
you he's got and he's he's so angry like
if anyone even questioned him you
probably just kill somebody for
questioning them you try to convince him
otherwise he'll just choke you out how
many how many bosses of his did he kill
ranking officers you don't care all
right Darth Vader don't care and well
Darth Vader spent the first half of the
first movie basically being talked down
to by gray suited Englishman okay so I
he puts up with a fare about a crap and
as Dan alluded to he gets talked but he
gets talked out of stuff a lot
danos look I understand that for Marvel
storytelling he had to take a long time
because they didn't know what they were
gonna do with him Bob LA I'm positing
that this character comes to our world
where I am eating cheeseburgers and I
get killed and this guy comes to the
McDonald's where I have been killed and
he cares about me and he goes oh god it
was that guy in the Pinto and he takes
his giant medley smashes Pinto and he
brews the guy's head off and then he
reanimates it what's so weird the Jim
and then he kills him again it kills him
again it kills him again that's what I'm
positing I understand you're Baba Yaga
is like oh he's relentless but he gets
hit by cars
he fights over dogs he's not he's not
the dude that mad Titan is I'm talking
about in this world in this world if he
came to this world Thanos could avenge
me better than any of these characters
and that was a criteria I based it on
time all right how about it three
powerful strong violent characters who
shall take it we shall see well I want
to go ahead and give us some facts and
then give us your opinion on the battle
got it no no incorrect facts that I
could surmise from this fight I do have
some John wick facts he kills 77 people
in his first movie
he's shocking a hundred and twenty eight
people in his second movie his shooting
accuracy is estimated at just above
eighty percent between the two films
that is it that is impressive if you're
John Wayne and so building over that I
thought this was a good choice but I
felt like a lot of the other arguments
kind of took took the wind out of some
of the sails of that is I especially
thought the the argument that he takes
too long he's too methodical and gradual
you want your revenge done tomorrow I
thought that was pretty convincing so
for me it came down to Vader versus John
wick I you know I think common sense
dictates that if those two guys were in
a room Vader could yeah just pulled his
hand up and sort of choked John wick out
but I have to say based on the arguments
I thought Dan dinner
job of describing how relentless John
wick would be whereas Vader is somebody
that yeah he's a puppet in a lot of ways
he sort of manipulated rolled by he's a
puppet not a felted friend is gonna
happen and so to me I sort of felt like
Dan overall was more convincing I'm
gonna go with John wick all right that's
one for John wick you know my thoughts
fall in line
similarly tollens I think you guys and
cucumber both positive answers who are
powerful kickass characters who could
destroy anybody you're like here's my
[ __ ] list they will take care of it for
you but just as far as like I think Dan
really got into the psychology of why
this man is on this mission and the
relentlessness I mean and Edie
man you you made me want to learn that
much more about the history of your
character and you brought up the comics
but since it is movie fights going by
all that we know about Thanos yeah these
guys could obviously wreck shop but
that's the guy to exact vengeance so
yeah
Dan gets the point it's John wick
Danielle what's the Internet's say about
it the internet agrees with 75% for John
wick 13% for Darth Vader 10% for Thanos
a lot of people say in Deadpool I want
to say this Twitter comment made me
laugh so much at gunner 9:21 said Carl
from up he is motivated surprisingly
athletic a killer bird and a pack of
incredibly violent and intelligent dogs
yeah yeah I like that Deadpool answer so
we have a dank memers oh no
I'm gonna have to spell this out P o IH
Pio on Twitter has imagined us as
legends of the screen junkies the Owls
of fandom so please go get some love for
this mspaint I cannot wait to see that
very love that I clearly took a long
time together I'm given that an R T
right after all right Dan Morelle
charges out to a 200 lead to 4 Dan Edie
and cucumber yet to get on the board
all right this is question number three
[Laughter]
to get crazy in here so I'm going to
have each of you pick a movie out of
this hat Oh cucumber
yeah these are kind of sticky so you can
just put your hand in and see if one
sticks oh that's not the meaning at all
[Laughter]
right I have no idea what's on any of
these here you go there's one for you
yeah all right at greer please go ahead
and pick one there we go
dan okay okay great I'm gonna read the
question and then we'll start with Dan
we'll go around and just hear your
answer and then we'll get into the
fightin okay the question pitch a remake
turning any original movie into an
erotic thriller yeah so like the steamy
nineties movie Basic Instinct or
something like that so yeah like a Joe
Esterhaus burst yeah
so picture remake turning any original
movie into an erotic thriller all right
Dan okay see what movie I've gotten are
we all gonna reveal or doing one at a
time oh yeah just reveal we'll just go
around and reveal Thor Ragnarok okay all
right man well here what happens with
thor ragnarok cucumber what do you would
you get
I got transformers trams
okay and Edie I got diehard
Wow there are three movies that I that
are not erotic thrillers but you are
each going to pitch the remake that
turns them into erotic thrillers and
yeah we've heard all of your answers so
let's just fight it out y'all jump into
the fray
all right well transformers is going to
be about you know the Allspark brought
all kinds of life to to the Transformers
but it didn't allow them the ability to
transform into their true selves so they
they go on a hunt and they find a new
device that allows them to to really
trance to make themselves transgender
Autobots right so they get they get
their new parts and and it's all about
the exploration you know Optimus Prime
and and and bumbly Bay and they all just
you know they're they start you know
they they get close they've known each
other for so long but not like this not
like this and they they breathe each
other's exhaust they check out each
other's tailpipes if you know what I
mean they really just get into it they
fight and then Megatron comes in but he
wants a taste too you know he's been in
that dam for so long it's just been
waiting to bust out and then you get the
constructed cons they come out with
those giant wrecking balls just to swing
in every whichaway
Wow pretty steamy pretty nice stuff and
steamy
yeah dan Edie jump in whenever I don't
know if I want to jump in there I mean
this is the thing
diehard is is not some tawdry Cinemax
flick like what cucumber was pitching
this is real deal
Joe Esterhaus esque erotica like Basic
Instinct or Jade or sometime
so basically John McClane comes to LA
and several of his girlfriends work in
the Nakatomi towers and he's has such
intense romantic history that were able
to back and forth in time with
flashbacks and stuff to the different to
different our relationships and when he
gets there it's like almost like a
cat-and-mouse game of trying to romance
but not be seen by the other women it's
tough but then it is revealed that one
of them is a terrorist who is who is
trying to rob the place and he has to a
series of erotic misadventures in
different rooms at different floors half
he has to use his sexual skills and it's
deductive skills to deduce who is the
who has a terrorist before they before
they accomplish their plot all right Dan
I would like to pitch a scene from my
film he and I an exploration really well
I think was only touched upon in the non
erotic thriller version of Thor Ragnarok
which is the romance between Thor
Odinson and The Incredible Hulk this
takes place somewhere in act 2 Thor has
been exiled to the prison planet a sacar
the Grand Master shows him to his
quarters is stripped to the waist
obviously very low lighting some smoke
little atmospheric smoke light saxophone
music playing in the background
Thor takes things in he's squinting to
adjust to the light and from from the
from the side of the room he hears a
splash and he looks and he sees the Hulk
emerging from the bath the Hulk is nude
of course these are old friends
these two they have a pass they have a
history but they've never really had the
opportunity to explore that history and
and from that from the moment they meet
the sparks are flying
Thor levitates himself to face level 4
the Hulk Lilly stands on a column of
lightning levitating ability and looked
deep into the Holtz green deep green
eyes it says it's been a while
and the hope says yes a while you know
it's been a long time since we spoke but
I I have to ask am i worthy the thor
reaches in grabs the Hulk's nape they
share a passionate embrace as only these
two friends can and then thor glances
downward as a smirk on his face and says
you made him angry but we're not getting
this good stuff till x3 so there's a
very tasteful pan away it's kind of like
through misted shower glass you see the
goings on and then we really explore as
the film draws to its conclusion finale
Wow Dan rural the master of the erotic
and really I think that the the erotic
tension has been there between these two
characters from the beginning and I
really want to see that explored and
it's a real change in direction for the
franchise which I think that's what they
were looking for to begin with and it's
a risk but I think this is going to be
something that people enjoy I'd also
like to note on a side note that my mom
flew into town today so I know she's
watching right now
I think I'm the only person who took
this seriously because I've set up a
mechanism whereby romantic events can
actually happen and progress I've set up
an actual plot that that that has errata
sysm as well as the you know detective
work intertwined as a process to get to
the end of the movie I've done those two
things this is one scene and this is
some cute stuff but I've actually
made a movie and and I just imagined the
scene where he's having sex with a lady
and then he leaves his gun and then she
starts she start speaking in her natural
German accent you know that's that scene
but erotic the son with her the scene
with the watch
the scene with the scene with the watch
and the watch in this movie is like a
symbol for well I guess you weren't the
right one consider that a divorce type
line you know it takes a lot Java drops
are out of the window you know I mean
there's all of the scenes that I don't
know what the the gun taped to the back
could be Edie and cucumber I would love
if possible to hear a clever catchphrase
like Dan had you're gonna get your
ragnaroks off if you have anything any
anything like that just from my like
personal amusement I really enjoy puns
well you know I just think he'll be
having sex with a lady inside of a air
duct and said I'd come out to the coves
have a few laughs that that's in the
trailer that's definitely in the trailer
okay all right a classic line from die
hard
cucumber what I want to make a pun about
dying hard
I respect your love resisting the
low-hanging fruit me I low-hanging fruit
I grab it right away just a number while
Megatron is pounding Optimus Prime and
the climax of this film and the climax
of Optimus Prime
he will scream out that's great cuz in
my movie it's the old voices good let's
go around for some final sauces on this
Dan we'll start with you again I would
like to point out that we were asked to
pitch an erotic thriller and and I feel
like Ed and cucumber have just a pitch
to just just flat-out pornography these
pictures are based on lust and just lust
between strangers and that's not what I
want an erotic thriller the errata sysm
comes from people with a history those
words and actions that have been unsaid
and undone for so many years and that's
what I get from every Avengers movie
between these two characters is I want
to see them speak these unspoken truths
that's the eroticism it's not just
random robots and people and air ducts
engaging in intercourse with them this
is about sexual tension and eroticism
and that's what I've got in this movie
and it's it's a key it's a key
ingredient that I don't feel either my
competitors have brought to their foams
thanks Dan cucumber I would like to
argue that all of the Transformers
characters have have a long and rich
history with each other especially
Optimus Prime and Megatron imagine how
difficult it would be for them to admit
their attraction to each other after
fighting each other for decades
generations really they've been fighting
for what thousands of years or something
ridiculous yeah you're gonna fetch it in
hell enemy but I think you know and the
sexual exploration of all their new
parts and bits is also a beautiful
addition on top of all the of the
lustful pounding all right lustful
pounding from cucumber Edie well I mean
I have a basic quibble with what the
that then was just breaking down about
this whole it isn't eroticism and erotic
thrillers are not about old love or
that's some remains of the day type
stuff you don't say it is erotic fillers
are not about unrequited love in any way
shape or form nor its erotic thrillers
are about the thrill of the new there's
a new sexual opportunity it leads you to
a new adventure and you have to deal
with the consequences of entering said
sexual adventure and to me that's what
my pitch for die hard is John McClane's
coming out to the west coast for the
first time he's encountering you know
he's countering a group that has a big
weird plot and in a building he has to
use his sexual and detective skills as
I've said before to Devine what's what's
going on it has applied by definition
and it is about new adventures that's
what erotic thrillers are about the new
adventure Basic Instinct isn't about a
detective who knew a lady for a long
time it's about oh this is a new weird
author lady let me have sex with her oh
gosh you might ice pick me that's that's
an erotic thriller and it's about new
not old time all right Wow I need a cold
shower after that round one shower us
with some fact was one factor actually
cucumber nailed this is milk and I'll
quote from the animated series millions
of years ago Cybertron was a planet of
peace until the Decepticons lusting for
power began a terrible war they have no
fighting for millions of years it's a
fact oh thank you thank you that's the
one that's one factor that right if I'm
giving if I'm giving my opinion I didn't
ask you for that
there's honestly all right Juan go ahead
oh so I everybody I thought had an
interesting pitch I felt like cucumber
it did feel very poorni to me I didn't
really feel like where's the story going
what water how's the thriller element
coming in it did sound like a great film
but just maybe not quite fitting into
the to the what we'd sort of come up
with here is the the kind of question
for dance I actually I mean obviously
that scene sounds great I want to see
more I want to know more but it felt a
little bit more like a Roma can erotic
romance I thought I really nailed coming
up with a framework that you could take
die hard and make it into a Esterhaus
style erotic thriller which was the
question so I'm going with that
okay yeah I when I wrap my head around
this I had to rank it IDI
third dance second cucumber first when
it came to the catchphrases love that
but I absolutely agree with lon
IDI laid out an entire film a potential
erotic thriller Dan had a very steamy
scene that that's titillated and de
piqued my interest
cucumber man you just got down to it
gonna make gonna make gonna make gonna
make Starscream say Oh bumblebee go but
and get the point
alright everyone else the same I have
learned so much from the chat and from
Twitter and three Oh today the chat with
40% it was thor ragnarok 33% for
die-hard 26% for transformers just go
check hashtag movie fights live
I can't even say half the stuff yellow
it is you are man some of the other
choices we have in the have we had a
bunch of fun ones oh boy
what what would the erotic thriller of
rocky look like the matrix you've got
mail yeah the erotic rope the erotic
rom-com standoff you got one it would
have been slam oh boy it's already
halfway there and Quint are probably the
most solo a Star Wars story men in black
in the Hat two others there were
demolition man and Lord of the Rings of
return oh yeah Sam and Frodo cucumber I
want to thank you but your title reign
ends today is yes cucumber thank you for
your short yet eventful reign and it's
been a pleasure you are man you've
really advanced my opinion of felted
friends yes and I noticed I haven't
called you a puppet all day yeah okay ed
Grier Dan Merle headed to the speed
round dan is up two to one the first
player to get four points on the board
walks out of hearing the opinion poll I
mean the poll will be up but Danielle's
opinion now we'll factor in as one of
the votes okay lon
Danielle and myself and again I will ask
the question in the speed round first
person to answer we'll go ahead and
elaborate on their answer first and
everyone gets 20 seconds 20 seconds and
then ten second rebuttal ten second
rebuttal
and again it's 2-1 damn four points wins
it fellas you already do this let's do
this question number one of the speed
round ah man this is late
breaking news r.i.p burt reynolds and in
honor of the late burt reynolds what's
the best Burt Reynolds movie Boogie
Nights
Cannonball Run all right Boogie Nights
versus Cannonball Run two iconic flicks
dan you answered first 20 seconds begin
when you speak Boogie Nights was the
film that I think defined the late era
of Burt Reynolds career and the one that
sort of allowed him to break out of
being Burt Reynolds the icon which he
was to so many people not only is it a
great performance from him it is a great
movie from Paul Thomas Anderson's shield
the promise that he would have it's a
great character study it's a great
period piece it's great on so many
different levels but again a career
redefining performance from Burton but
see that's the thing
Burt Reynolds as a movie star has a
distinct high point and it is a round
Cannonball Run time and he was the
biggest star in the world he could have
a franchise built around him just
driving around in his car and doing
stuff III really think that it was a
graduation of the Smokey and the Bandit
concept to more of a I think Cannonball
Run is a memorable Burt Reynolds movie
as you said it was around that time I
think there's a lot of other
performances and movies like Smokey and
the Bandit Cannonball Run 2 other
smoking abandon sequels that go in that
same way and whereas Boogie Nights
Boogie Nights is a nice trick Dan and
you're good at the tricks that it is a
good movie with Burt Reynolds in it but
he does not star in that movie he is a
co-star Mark Wahlberg's Johnson is
better star them all right two very
different films from Burt Reynolds all
right oh I both of these argued
beautifully I'm gonna have to do one of
those semantics things that I know that
we all hate and they're super unfun but
edie really had me when he said Boogie
Nights is a great movie with Burt
Reynolds in it but it is not necessarily
like known for being a Burt Reynolds
movie I know that is a semantics but I
feel like the way that he snuck that in
with that of being able to be fought for
was such a like great debate technique
that
go for it all right that's one for ED
lon I thought I did a great job of
arguing why cannibal red represents sort
of the high point in the timeline of
Burt but damn did a better job
bargaining specifically why Boogie
Nights was the better sort of film for
Burt Reynolds uh I'm going thin all
right so yeah this is a real difficult
one you guys both so close but yeah the
question what is the best Burt Reynolds
movie like semantically Oh is it is it
the movie or is it the Burt Reynolds
vehicle movie like the as a vehicle for
him I feel like just by the hair on our
chinny chin Chin's ed takes this one for
me with the point that Danielle said and
it really locking in and as the high
point of his career so it is 2 2 we are
locked up at 2 - Wow all tied up
question number 2 of the speed round
what movie character would you want
defending your neighborhood Laurie
Strode from Halloween or Kevin
McCallister from home alone Kevin
McCallister Laurie Strode okay we have
Kevin McCallister and Laurie Strode from
Dan Kevin McAllister from Edie Edie you
spoke first 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak now look man you ain't never
seen you know pain until you fell on a
bunch of max boxcars or ahead and Payton
can't stand up against your head I mean
they shooting Michael Myers all the time
but if paint cans a whole nother thing
man what he did to the slippery bandits
I don't even think Michael Myers would
come in - Kevin McCallister's
neighborhood you notice he go he lives
in Haddonfield not regular Chicago where
Kevin lives Laurie Strode is a fighter
she is a warrior and she is a survivor
I'll give Kevin McAllister creativity
points but when it comes down to it I
want somebody with that survival
instinct and somebody that is going to
fight not just for her lives but as we
saw in the first Halloween movie is
gonna fight for the lives of the kids
she was babysitting she's not just
protecting herself she's protecting
those in her care
kevin is not he's very selfish I believe
that's Kevin's edge Kevin doesn't have
any emotionality in this okay yeah the
Kevin doesn't have any emotionality in
this Kevin is just a pure destruction
machine much like Michael Myers himself
and Laurie is just a Newton I would also
like to point out that Kevin McAllister
had to be rescued twice and he would not
be alive if we're not for old man Marley
and the pigeon lady they had to save
this bacon every time he tried to defend
on his own breads Laurie Strode survived
many Halloween's okay Wow you know what
that last point right there by Dan and
undefendable it was just like yes it
sent Ed's argument reeling right there I
got to go Dan Merle on that long
totally agree also they're the Wet
Bandits or the sticky bandits anyway
yeah dan really with that with that
final argument put this one away I go
dad yeah okay
dan hops back into the lead it is three
two
Wow this is I mean man bolts on line
great moment in sports you guys alum
nation pumped right now oh hell yeah
okay
question number three of the speed round
by the way this is game point Dan Edie
you need this to keep the game going
who's the all-time scariest horror movie
villain Prady
Pazuzu the devil the the demon from The
Exorcist I'm counting it okay so you
said Freddy and we have Pazuzu the demon
from The Exorcist all right we heard
Freddy first edie 20 seconds again when
you speak I do understand the Exorcist
is a classic but look I'm not scared of
13 year old girls with a devil in them I
just leave the house I don't care I
don't have it but you can't escape your
dreams okay you can't escape your dreams
you can't escape his mechanism even if
you fight back most time you lose Freddy
is an enduring demon whereas like I said
you can walk out of the house with his
I think the terrifying thing about
Pazuzu is that it is not a corporeal
entity and it's not an entity that only
appears in your dreams it is an entity
that will not haunt you it will possess
you it will take control of you and you
will lose control and I think that is a
primal visceral fear that you lose
control of yourself and are taken over
by an evil entity
I can fight Freddie I can come back
Freddie I cannot combat demonic
possession that needs to be done for me
I contend that the fear that that's
represented in that movie is that
someone you love will be taken over by
said demon not you yourself that is the
fear that has been explored in there
whereas Freddie will kill you
specifically you but again Pazuzu is
evil and evil can't be defeated Freddie
it can be defeated by so many different
ways but Pazuzu is again that may be
something that you are not afraid of but
I am viscerally afraid of the idea of
losing yourself not fighting something
time whew fellas man you are making our
jobs hard today let's start with
Danielle no no I'm still taking notes
um yeah once again fantastic arguments
[Music]
ultimately for this one I do have to say
it was almost like when they're fighting
crazy they're fighting two different
things whether it's the fear of someone
you love being taken or whether it is
the fear of yourself ultimately being
possessed I do think that Dan's argument
was stronger for me so I'm gonna go with
Dan although I will say you can't escape
your dreams someone put that on a shirt
or like yeah in listening to arguments I
mean I thought okay Freddy is the
scarier villain when I laid on top of it
but Dan your opening salvo the way you
just broke down the fear and how
visceral it was and like you took me
there like you're opening answer took me
there to that feeling of fear so just
because of that and because I was I did
not know the name was Pazuzu so just
having that in your back pocket
impressed right out of the gate heed
great choice but Dan your answer took it
for me dad you are the new movie fights
champion and so well cucumber oh my
goodness Wow dan this is oh thank you
how man well you know the the duty of
every movie fights champion is first and
foremost to wish a happy birthday to the
voice of the people miss Danielle
Radford
[Applause]
Danielle if are you able to come over
here you are I'm locked and miked
but I can probabily
what are you all so much I didn't know
about this
[Applause]
[Music]
the erotic thriller my goodness Danielle
what's your birthday wish no you can't
tell us that happy birthday Danielle
yeah what's your what's your wish for
the Internet on your birthday you might
want to borrow Ed's my wish for the
Internet is like more kindness and hire
me to do more jobs congratulations
good block all y'all mother effers
taking that belt away from dad loves it
belts for a long time career you brought
it as always host of the nerdo podcast
[Applause]
for all those out there that thought
this was a foregone conclusion I think
me and cubes showed that it was not dan
is an actual champion this isn't destiny
this is skill and one day one of us
would one of us is gonna clubber Lang up
and beat his ass until that day he's in
the sunshine so I just want to make that
clear and I please listen to the nerd
goat podcast we're a five-star rated
podcast and I would love for more screen
junkies to be down with it because
that's the way to be down with me hell
yeah
always a pleasure having you brother
cucumber once again tell us where we can
find you Jamie's last perception studio
also AM hyper APG on Monday nights
awesome thanks buddy and Ross Joestar OH
for everything blonde thank you for
holding it down on the facts JT in the
booth max I see over there hi buddy
thank you for watching screen junkies
and movie fights owl nation we'll see
you next week bye everybody
you